Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. TD Direct Investing offers live support, so whether you're a newbie or a seasoned pro, you can make your investing steps count. And if you're like me and think a TFSA stands for Total Fund Savings Adventure, maybe reach out to TD Direct Investing. Frenchman, where now are those qualities which once distinguished you? Where now is that national character of greatness and loyalty? Would you show your powers in overwhelming with misfortunes the man who had the noble
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。若想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。TD Direct Investing 提供实时支持，因此无论你是新手还是经验丰富的老手，都能让你的投资稳扎稳打。如果你和我一样，认为 TFSA 代表的是“全资基金探险之旅”（Total Fund Savings Adventure），或许可以联系一下 TD Direct Investing。法国人啊，曾经让你们引以为傲的那些品质现在在哪里？曾经伟大的民族性格和忠诚现在在哪里？你们是要用灾难来压倒那位以高贵的
resolution to repose such confidence in you, have you no more respect for the sacred duties of hospitality? Is no commiseration due to such unparalleled misfortunes? Do you not think that a king who ceases to be one is not a victim sufficiently striking, without its being necessary to add such accumulated miseries to his fate. Frenchman, this revolution which regenerates you develops great qualities, but fear, lest it should at the same time efface humanity from your heart, without which every other virtue is lost.
决心对你们寄予如此信任的人，借此展现你们的力量吗？你们对神圣的待客职责难道再无敬意？对如此空前的灾难难道就没有一丝怜悯？你们难道不认为，一个不再身为国王的君王已经是一个足够震撼的牺牲品，无需再将如此沉重的苦难叠加到他的命运之中吗？法国人啊，这场令你们重生的革命激发了伟大的品质，但要小心，莫让它同时抹去了你们心中的人性，失去了人性，其他一切美德都将荡然无存。
So that was the somewhat florid concluding statement of a fellow called Romand de Cez, who was a lawyer from Bordeaux. Tom writes here that he was celebrated for his sonorous eloquence. As I think you can tell. Tom tell rights here that he was celebrated for his sonorous eloquence. As I think you can tell, as you can tell, there he was standing on the 26th of December, 1792, before the national convention in Paris. And of course the man he was defending who was on trial for his life was the erstwhile King Louis the 16th.
以上是罗曼·德·塞兹（Romand de Cez）这位来自波尔多的律师有些辞藻华丽的结辩陈词。汤姆在这里写道，他以铿锵有力的雄辩而闻名。正如我想你能看出的那样。汤姆·赖特在这里写道，他以铿锵有力的雄辩而闻名。正如我想你能看出的那样，正如你所见，1792年12月26日，他正站在巴黎的国家国民公会前。当然，他所辩护的那位正因生死关头而受审的男子，便是曾经的国王路易十六。
And this Tom is one of those speeches that defines the French Revolution the French Revolution is a great rhetorical event yeah and we've done a lot of great orations we had Saint Just last time saying that you can't reign innocently and the king must die and here we have Chormad XVI saying that you should fear lest you face humanity from your heart and you should find the compassion for this man who has suffered enough. And basically nobody listens. Well I think some people do listen as we will see but they from Louis point of view don't
而且汤姆，这正是那些定义了法国大革命的演讲之一。法国大革命是一场伟大的修辞盛宴，是的，我们做过很多伟大的演讲，上次我们有圣茹斯特说你不能无罪地统治，国王必须死；而这里我们有德·塞兹说，你们应该当心，莫要让仁慈从你们心中抹去，你们应该对这个已经饱受苦难的人抱有一丝同情。基本上没人听进去。嗯，我想有些人确实听进去了，正如我们将会看到的，但从路易的角度来看，他们
listen hard enough I think you could say. And that translation that you read, it was issued, published only a few weeks after it was delivered. So it was rushed translated into English. And I guess it's a reminder of just how seismic an event the trial of the King of France is. I mean, it completely transfixes France, obviously, but Britain, all of Europe. I mean, it's the most astonishing spectacle. And in Britain and in the other monarchies of Europe, public opinion, by and large, is appalled. Even though obviously in England, the English had actually set a precedent because they had tried and executed a king
听得还不够认真，你可以这么说。你所读的那篇翻译稿，是在它发表后仅仅几周内就出版了。所以它是仓促被翻译成英文的。我想这也提醒了我们，法国国王的审判是何等震撼的事件。我的意思是，它显然彻底震撼了法国，还有英国、整个欧洲。我的意思是，这是一场最令人震惊的奇观。在英国和欧洲的其他君主国中，公众舆论总体上感到震惊。尽管显然在英国，英国人实际上已经开创了一个先例，因为他们曾审判并处决了一位国王
themselves in the form of Charles I. Not uncontroversial, right? Right. But it's not just in foreign monarchies that public opinion is appalled because there are also deep reservoirs of royalism in France and the assumption that a king is inviolate, down to the most basic level that people shouldn't touch him without kind of strict protections of ritual and so on. This is deeply, deeply ingrained. It's been a theme of French history for a millennium and more. And that sense that a king's actions are inviolate, It had been so hardwired that it had been written into the constitution that had been issued in 1791 and which Louis had accepted. And in that it had specified that only if a king had set himself at the head of a hostile
他们自己，即查理一世。这并非没有争议，对吧？没错。但不仅在外国君主国中，公众舆论感到震惊，因为在法国国内也存在着对保王主义的深厚积淀，以及那种认为国王神圣不可侵犯的假设，一直到最基础的层面上——人们不应该触碰他，除非有那种严格的仪式保护等等。这种观念根深蒂固。它一直是法国历史上延续了千年之久的主题。而那种认为国王的行为不可侵犯的意识，已经如此深入人心，以至于它被写入了1791年颁布并被路易接受的宪法中。其中明确规定，只有当路易将自己置于敌对的
army could he be reckoned to have abdicated the throne. But otherwise, and this is something that Louis himself points out at his trial, the king's person is inviolable and sacred. That is what the constitution had said. But we've been talking about this second revolution that has overwhelmed Paris and France over the course of 1792. And it is precisely that sense of inviolability, precisely the sense that the King's very body is somehow sacred, that the deputies in the national convention are, you know, that is what they're trying to destroy. They're not just trying to destroy the person of Louis, they're trying to destroy the figure of the King and everything, all the sacrality that is associated with him. And that's why they're bringing him to trial. That's the whole point of it.
军队首领地位时，才能被视为放弃了王位。除此之外，这也是路易本人在审判中指出的，国王的人身是不可侵犯且神圣的。宪法就是这么规定的。但我们一直在讨论这场席卷了1792年巴黎和法国的第二场革命。恰恰是这种不可侵犯的意识，恰恰是那种认为国王的肉体在某种程度上是神圣的意识，国民公会的代表们——你知道，这正是他们试图摧毁的东西。他们不仅试图摧毁路易这个人，他们还试图摧毁国王这个形象以及与之相关的一切神圣性。这就是他们把路易送上审判台的原因。这才是问题的关键。
And of course, they know that the eyes of the world upon them, the international situation for this is incredibly important. We were talking yesterday about these amazing successes that French arms have been having, going into Switzerland and into Nice and into Austria and Netherlands, what's now Belgium. And the justification for this is precisely the overthrow, not just of tyranny and monarchy in France, but across Europe, across the world. I mean, we were saying that the French revolutionary leaders are seeing what they're doing in cosmic terms. It's kind of a Trotskyite in that sense, isn't it? It's interesting how that has escalated from an opposition to this king, which would have been
当然，他们知道全世界的目光都聚焦在他们身上，这对国际局势来说极其重要。我们昨天还在谈论法军取得的那些惊人胜利，他们进军瑞士、尼斯、奥地利以及尼德兰，也就是现在的比利时。而这一切的合法性正源于推翻暴政和君主制，不仅在法国，更要推翻全欧洲、全世界的暴政与君主制。我的意思是，我们当时说过，法国革命领袖们是从宇宙级的高度来看待他们的所作所为的。从某种意义上说，这有点像托洛茨基主义，不是吗？有趣的是，这种敌意是如何升级的：从一年前反对这个国王——
the case a year earlier, that this king is complicit with counter-revolutionaries and foreign infiltrators and all that kind of thing. But it has widened, hasn't it? They've self-radicalised, so now it is in opposition to all kings and to kingship more generally and so this has become more than just a case about Louis and his own personal misdemeanours. He is on trial as a symbol of worldwide despotism and monarchy. Yeah, so it's monarchy, it's a very concept of monarchy itself. So one of the deputies who's pushing for the guilty verdict on the king says that the verdict that is delivered on Louis must serve as an example for all nations. So this is very pointed. If it's Louis the 16th today, then perhaps
认为这个国王与反革命分子和外国潜伏人员同流合污，诸如此类。但它的范围扩大了，不是吗？他们进行了自我激进化，所以现在的立场是反对所有的国王以及更广泛意义上的君主制，因此这已经不仅仅是一场关于路易及其个人不端行为的案件了。他作为全世界专制和君主制的象征而接受审判。是的，所以这是针对君主制，针对君主制本身的整个概念。因此，一位推动对国王做出有罪判决的议员表示，对路易做出的判决必须成为所有国家的榜样。所以这是非常尖锐的。如果今天是路易十六，那么也许
it will be George the third, you know, in a court in London tomorrow. That's a horrendous thought, Tom. Well, okay. We said we shouldn't exaggerate how focused on other countries the delegates are. I mean, they are, but of course their real focus is on France itself. And again, we talked yesterday how it's important for the new republic because there hasn't been a formal proclamation of a republic. So just to quote Antoine de Bec. Dominic, do you want to insert your joke there? He was late, so I want to insert your joke there? He was later on Strictly Come Dancing, that's the joke.
明天就会是伦敦法庭上的乔治三世了。这是一个可怕的想法，汤姆。好吧，好吧。我们说过，我们不应该夸大代表们对其他国家的关注程度。我的意思是，他们确实关注，但当然他们真正的焦点还是法国本身。同样，我们昨天讨论过，这对新共和国来说有多重要，因为当时并没有对共和国进行正式的公告。引述安东尼·德·贝克的话。多米尼克，你想在那里插播你的笑话吗？他后来上了《舞动奇迹》，这就是那个笑话。
Very good. So he wrote this great book, Glory and Terror, Seven Deaths under the French Revolution. And the Princess de Lambelle is one of those seven deaths, but Louis XVI is another. And he writes, when France entered into a republic in the course of the summer of 1792, it did not solemnly proclaim the foundation of a new regime. The historian can look nowhere will he unearth an official decree in the archives installing the first French Republic. So you do have the image of liberty on the, on the melted royal seal. We talked about that, but otherwise there isn't really anything kind of symbolically resonant. And I guess that that is what Saint-Just had fixed on in his famous speech when you quoted him yesterday that the king simply by virtue of being a king is guilty since Sanjus puts it,
很好。所以他写了那本伟大的书《光荣与恐怖：法国大革命下的七次死亡》。德·朗巴勒王妃是这七次死亡之一，而路易十六是另一个。他写道：“当法国在1792年夏天进入共和国时期时，它并没有庄严宣告新政权的建立。历史学家无处可寻，在档案中也找不到一份确立第一法兰西共和国的官方法令。”所以你在融化的皇家印章上确实看到了自由女神的形象。我们讨论过这个，但在其他方面并没有什么具有象征共鸣的东西。我想这正是圣茹斯特在他昨天被你引用的那场著名演讲中所锁定的目标：国王仅仅因为身为国王就是有罪的，正如圣茹斯特所说，
one cannot reign innocently. And so it's only when the king has been put to death that the Republic can properly be born. So in the Marseilles, there's talk about tainted blood fertilizing the soil. And I'm sure that that must be kind of part of what the deputies are thinking. They want a big set piece. Yeah, but his blood will fertilize the soil and enable the Republic to kind of flourish and grow and emerge. And there's a sense in which therefore, I think, the deposition,
人们无法无罪地统治。因此，只有当国王被处决时，共和国才能真正诞生。所以，在《马赛曲》中，有关于用受污染的土壤来给土地施肥的说法。我确信这一定是议员们思考的一部分。他们想要一场宏大的重头戏。是的，但他的鲜血将滋养这片土地，并使共和国能够繁荣、成长和崛起。因此，在某种程度上，我认为废黜、
the imprisonment, the trial, and perhaps if he's found guilty, the execution of the king will serve the French Republic as all the various declarations in the American Revolution served the American Republic. It's the ritualistic kind of kickoff, isn't it? And you say if he's found guilty, there was no doubt that he will be found guilty from the beginning. I mean, we're going to be talking about the trial, but I don't think there's any doubts in anybody's mind that he's not going to be walking out a free man kind of punching the
囚禁、审判，或许如果他被判有罪，对国王的处决，将为法兰西共和国服务，就像美国革命中的各种宣言为美利坚共和国所服务的那样。这是一种仪式性的开端，对吧？你刚才说如果他被判有罪——其实从一开始就毫无疑问他会被判有罪。我的意思是，我们将讨论这场审判，但我认为没有人会怀疑他会大摇大摆地走出法庭，在老贝利街外面挥拳庆祝。
air and stuff outside the old Bailey. No, no, I just wanted to maintain the suspense. Yeah. Okay. It's about the jeopardy. Okay. Very dramatic tensions. So tell us exactly how he is brought to trial.
不，不，我只是想保持悬念。好吧。是为了制造危机感。好吧。极具戏剧性的张力。那么，请确切告诉我们他是如何被送上审判台的。
Okay. So tell us exactly how he is brought to trial. Okay, so on the 10th of December, the formal indictment is read out in the National Convention and Louis is charged with conspiring with the enemies of the French nation against the Republic and therefore of direct treason. And essentially what they do is they go back over everything that he's done since the outbreak of the revolution in 1789 and they present it in the worst light possible. And if you're a royalist, you might say, well, this is very harsh. Personally, I think actually they've got to be pretty bad to write because he has been working to undo the revolution. And the thing is, is that the worst thing that he's been doing, which is essentially,
好吧。那么，请确切告诉我们他是如何被送上审判台的。好吧，12月10日，正式起诉书在国民公会中宣读，路易被控与法兰西民族的敌人勾结，反对共和国，因此犯有直接叛国罪。本质上，他们回顾了自1789年革命爆发以来他所做的一切，并以最恶劣的眼光将其呈现出来。如果你是一个保王党人，你可能会说，这太严苛了。就我个人而言，我认为他们其实必须写得相当严厉，因为路易确实一直在试图瓦解革命。最糟糕的事情在于，基本上，
you know, he has been conspiring with the Austrians. He has been writing to monarchs of hostile nations. That correspondence has not come to light, even when the safe was opened. That evidence of that had gone because Louis and Marie Antoinette had been sensible enough to actually burn that. So they don't even know the worst of it.
你知道，他一直在与奥地利人勾结。他一直在给敌对国家的君主写信。虽然即使在保险箱被打开时，这些信件也没有曝光——因为路易和玛丽·安托瓦内特足够聪明，把它们烧掉了。所以他们甚至不知道最糟糕的情况。
So as you say, I think the evidence is pretty bad that he has been betraying the revolution. So the following day on the 11th of December, he is summoned to the convention to face the charges that are going to be leveled against him. And the summons is brought to him by the mayor of Paris. He of course is in the temple where he's been locked up for about four months. The mayor comes into his presence, doesn't take his hat off, doesn't bow, addresses him as Louis Capet. And we talked about that yesterday, that Capet is the family name of Hugh Capet,
正如你所说，我认为有足够的证据证明他背叛了革命。因此，在接下来的12月11日，他被传唤到国民公会，以面对将要对他提出的指控。传票由巴黎市长交给他。他当然被关在已经关了大约四个月的圣殿塔里。市长来到他面前，没有脱帽，没有鞠躬，直呼他为路易·卡佩。我们昨天谈到过，卡佩是于格·卡佩的家族姓氏，
who had been elected king at the end of the 10th century. And Louis is very indignant and points out that he is not a Capay, that he is a Bourbon, because the Capays had gone extinct in the early 14th century, which is what had kicked off the Hundred Years War. They'd been replaced by the Valois and then the Valois had gone extinct and they'd been replaced by the Bourbon. And so why Capay? The reason is precisely because it enables the Republic to demonstrate that it's not just Louis who's on trial. It's the entire line of all the kings that join Hugh Capay to Louis the 16th.
于格·卡佩在10世纪末被选为国王。路易感到非常愤慨，指出他不是卡佩，而是波旁，因为卡佩王朝在14世纪初就已经绝嗣了，这也是引发百年战争的原因。他们被瓦卢瓦王朝取代，然后瓦卢瓦王朝绝嗣，又被波旁王朝取代。那么为什么要叫卡佩？原因恰恰在于，这让共和国能够证明，受审的不仅仅是路易一个人，而是将从于格·卡佩到路易十六的所有国王一网打尽。
So the trial is doing two things simultaneously, right? It is trying Louis as a private individual who has betrayed the revolution. but it's also doing that Saint-Juice thing of trying him as a symbol of monarchy. He stands in effectively for all the monarchs that France has ever had. Yeah. And I think there's an inherent ambivalence there because on the one hand, the emphasis is on his role now as someone who has been decrowned, who is just a normal citizen. But of course he isn't. He has to be tried as a king as well.rowned, who is just a normal citizen. But of course, he isn't. He has to be tried as a king as well. So there's a kind of a slight ambivalence
因此，审判同时在做两件事，对吧？它既是在审判一个背叛了革命的私隐个人，但它同时也在做圣茹斯特那种事——将他作为君主制的象征来审判。他实际上代表了法国曾经拥有过的所有君主。是的。我认为其中存在一种固有的矛盾，因为一方面，重点在于他现在作为废王的角色，他只是一个普通公民。但当然他并不是。他必须作为国王接受审判。因此存在一种微妙的矛盾，
there that shadows the entire approach of the Republic to Louis and to his fate. So he leaves the temple, as we said, for the first time in about four months, a massive lines of soldiers along the streets of the National Guard to make sure that no rescue attempts can be made. He is brought into the convention. He's led to the bar. He is obviously dressed as a private citizen. An onlooker describes him as wearing just a plain yellowish frock coat. He walks in, he looks around, everyone is sat, everyone has their hats on, and onlookers are delighted by his expression of kind of consternation really. And so one of them wrote, no doubt he was quite surprised to see no other seat for him
这种矛盾贯穿了共和国对待路易及其命运的整个方式。正如我们所说，他大约四个月来首次离开圣殿塔，国民卫队的士兵在巴黎街头排起长龙，以确保不会发生任何营救企图。他被带到国民公会。他被带到审判栏前。他显然穿着平民的衣服。一个旁观者形容他只穿着一件朴素的 yellowish（微黄色的）长礼服。他走进来，环顾四周，每个人都坐着，每个人都戴着帽子，旁观者对他的那种真正可以说是惊愕的表情感到高兴。其中一人写道：“毫无疑问，他非常惊讶地发现，在那个他曾不止一次展现过皇室傲慢与礼仪的地方，
than a humble chair in a place where he had more than once deployed all the pride and ceremony of royalty. Remember readers, the scarlet armchair with Fleur de Lis, which insulted the representatives of the nation. And of course, he is only allowed to sit when he is given permission to do so by the president of the court. And this is to turn the world upside down. You think of all the ritual that had governed behavior at Versailles and it's utterly upended isn't it? This is very execution of Charles the first isn't it? We did two episodes about that with our friend Ted Valance.
留给他的座位竟然只是一把简陋的椅子。”读者们，请记住那把绣有百合花饰的猩红扶手椅，它曾侮辱过国家的代表。当然，只有得到法庭庭长的许可，他才能坐下。这简直是把世界颠倒过来了。想想所有曾支配凡尔赛宫行为的礼仪，它被彻底颠覆了，不是吗？这非常类似于查理一世的审判，对吧？我们和我们的朋友泰德·瓦伦斯一起做过两期关于这个的节目。
Remember there's all that business where a bit of Charles' cane falls off and no one picks it up and yeah and he has to get it yeah yeah this is all exactly the same thing again and obviously they all know the story of Charles the first so there must be a slight element of role playing on all sides actually, that they're kind of conscious that this has happened before. Yeah, and as we will see, Louis is very familiar with the story of Charles' trial. And it's probably that that enables him, you know, having read that, having read how Charles maintained his dignity in that situation, I'm sure it must steal Louis in this situation because when the charges
还记得那些情节吗：查理的手杖掉了一截，没有人去捡，然后他不得不自己去拿……是的，这一切完全是一回事。显然他们都知道查理一世的故事，所以各方其实都有一种微妙的角色扮演成分，他们都意识到这种事以前发生过。是的，正如我们将看到的，路易对查理审判的故事非常熟悉。可能正是这一点让他能够——读过那些内容，读过查理在这种情况下如何保持尊严之后，我相信这一定在此时坚定了路易的心志，因为当指控
are read out, he is very calm in denying them. People say, even those who are hostile to him say he seems very serene. And even when he's shown these papers with his signature on that have been taken from the safe, that he's clearly banged to rights. And he just said, that's not my signature, it's nothing to do with me at all. And the only time he actually displays any sense of outrage or indignation is when he's accused of shedding French blood. And then he is indignant. He protests. He says, this is absolutely false. And their reaction to his performance, the Montagnards, so the radicals, Robespierre, Marais and so on, they view this as the rankest hypocrisy that he is blatantly lying.
被宣读时，他非常平静地否认了这些指控。人们说，即使是那些对立的人也说他看起来非常平静。甚至当向他展示那些从保险箱里拿出来的、带有他签名的文件时，他的罪证明明已经确凿，他却只是说：“那不是我的签名，跟我一点关系也没有。”他唯一一次表现出任何愤怒或愤慨的时候，是当他被指控流淌了法国人的鲜血时。那时他才感到愤慨。他抗议。他说：“这绝对是假的。”山岳派（即激进派，如罗伯斯庇尔、马拉等）对他的表现的反应是，他们认为这是最极致的虚伪，他在公然撒谎。
A majority of people in the convention though, I think they feel sufficiently sympathetic that they decide that Louis should be allowed legal representation because that had not been decided until this point. So Louis taken back to the temple and he is then allowed to request legal representation. And so the person he goes for is the guy who probably has the most formidable reputation of any of the lawyers who had been operating in the Auxerre regime. And this is the guy who had led the defense of the Prince de Rohing in the affair of the diamond necklace.
不过，国民公会中的多数人似乎感到足够的同情，他们决定应该允许路易拥有法律辩护，因为这一点直到此时才决定。因此，路易被带回圣殿塔，随后被允许申请法律辩护。他所挑选的人，大概是旧政权时期活跃的所有律师中名声最为显赫的那位。这个人就是领导了钻石项链案中罗昂亲王辩护的人。
The cardinal guy. The cardinal, the cardinal de Rohing, who by successfully defending the cardinal de Rohing had done terrible damage to Marie Antoinette and to Louis XVI himself, to the very image of the crown. That seems a long time ago now, doesn't it? Doesn't it? The diamond necklace affair.
那个枢机主教。枢机主教，罗昂枢机主教。他通过成功为罗昂枢机主教辩护，对玛丽·安托瓦内特和路易十六本人、对王室的形象造成了可怕的损害。那似乎是很久以前的事了，不是吗？不是吗？钻石项链案。
And it must have done to Louis himself, because even though this guy, who's a man called Guyillaume Baptiste had inflicted these wounds on the monarchy, in the revolution itself, he had been a very enthusiastic supporter of constitutional monarchy. So he'd been a member of the third estate, but had been a kind of constitutional monarchist. And he'd stuck to that. And he was the guy who'd come up with the idea that Louis should no longer be king of France But should be king of the French
这对路易本人来说一定也是如此，因为尽管这个人——一个名叫纪尧姆-巴蒂斯特（Guillaume Baptiste）的人曾给君主制造成了这些创伤，但在革命本身中，他曾是君主立宪制的非常热情的支持者。所以他曾是第三等级的成员，但属于某种君主立宪派。而且他一直坚持这一点。他就是那个提出路易不应再是法兰西国王，
That's very much where he's at But because of that, of course, he now seems a counter-revolutionary The guy who had been at the cutting edge of radicalism in 1788 now seems, you know Total reactionary and he's aware of this and so he says he's not going to do it But there's also an issue. He's got an issue to be fair to him with his weight, hasn't he? He says, he says, basically, I'm too fat to stand up in court. That's his excuse.
而应该是法国人的国王这一想法的人。这非常符合他的立场。但正因为如此，他现在看起来像个反革命分子。这个在1788年处于激进主义前沿的人，现在看起来成了一个彻头彻尾的反动派，他意识到了这一点，所以他说他不会接手。但这里还有一个问题，说句公道话，他连自己的体重都有问题，不是吗？他说，他基本上说：“我太胖了，在法庭上站不住。”这就是他的借口。
So this had been this had been royalist abuse leveled at him right the way back in the trial of the Cardinal to Rohan that he'd simply been too fat even to stand up. But now he takes advantage of this says I can't possibly, you know, I'll just keel over if I have to stand up all this time. So that's his excuse. Now, fortunately for Louis, there are people who are brave enough to volunteer for the job of defending him. And one of them is our friend Olympe de Gouges. The feminist. Yes. So she has not been keeping her head out of the firing line. She has been publicly attacking Robespierre, attacking Marat. She's very identified with the Girondin, who she sees as being much more sympathetic to
所以早在罗昂枢机主教的审判中，保王党人就曾以此来攻击他，说他胖得连站都站不稳。但现在他利用了这一点，说：“我绝对不可能……如果我一直站着，我就会晕倒的。”这就是他的借口。现在，对路易幸存的是，还有一些人勇敢地志愿为他辩护。其中一位就是我们的朋友奥兰普·德古热。女权主义者。是的。所以她并没有让自己置身于战火之外。她一直在公开攻击罗伯斯庇尔，攻击马拉。她与吉伦特派紧密联系，认为吉伦特派对
female suffrage. And people may remember that she was very, very fond of Louis. She viewed him as having been dealt a bad hand. And even as the king is being brought to trial, she issues a public statement declaring that the greatest of Louis' crimes is to have been king at a time when philosophy was silently preparing the foundations of our Republic. We have abolished royalty. He has lost his subjects, has thrown everything. Let us be good enough to leave him his life." And I think in saying that, she's probably speaking for a sizable number of the French who probably do feel that.
女性选举权更加同情。人们可能还记得，她非常非常喜欢路易。她认为路易抽到了一手烂牌。甚至在国王受审时，她也发表了一份公开声明，宣称路易最大的罪行就是在哲学正在悄悄筹备我们共和国基础的时代当了国王。“我们已经废除了王室。他失去了臣民，一切都已失去。让我们大发慈悲，留他一男性命吧。”我想她这么说，大概代表了相当一部分确实有这种感觉的法国人。
I mean, you could say she might be being naive because by leaving him alive, you would create problems for the future. But you know, she's being commendably compassionate, Tom. Well, this is not how the Saint-ot see it. So they are, they are, they're furious at this and a large mob gathers outside her house with the bravery that is absolutely typical of her. Olimpidogouge goes down and confronts them on her doorstep and one of the soncolot grabs her by her hair, you know, holding up her face to the crowd and says, you know, let's, let's chop this off.
我的意思是，你可以说她可能太天真了，因为留他活着会给未来制造麻烦。但你知道，她表现出了值得称赞的同情心，汤姆。嗯，圣茹斯特派可不这么看。所以他们对此感到愤怒，一大群暴民聚集在她的屋外。凭借着绝对符合她性格的勇敢，奥兰普·德古热走出去，在门廊上与他们对质。其中一个无套裤汉抓住她的头发，把她的脸抬起来对着人群说：“让我们把它砍掉吧。”
I'm going to auction it off. Who would, who bids for her head? Olymp de Gouges puts in a massive bid. And this is treated by the crowd as, you know, immense banter, hilarious. And, um, and so they, they let her off. Right. So her good humor, um, her ability to make a joke in the teeth of, of mob violence, um, enables her to, to fight another day. But Louie doesn't fancy her as his legal representative.
“我要把它拿去拍卖。谁来出价买她的头？”奥兰普·德古热出了一个天价。人群把这当作巨大的玩笑，觉得极其滑稽。于是他们放过了她。没错。所以她的幽默感，她在面对暴民暴力时开玩笑的能力，使她能够继续斗争。但路易并看不起她作为他的法律代表。
No, I wouldn't have been amazing if he had. Yeah. He is not sufficiently progressive to do that. Right. Fortunately, there is another guy who volunteers, um, and this is a man called Guillaume Chrétien de Mauserbe. And he is the absolute embodiment of kind of enlightenment infused liberalism. So he was a friend of Rousseau, he corresponded with Diderot, he'd been the national censor
不，如果他选了她，那该多惊艳啊。是的。他还没有开明到那种程度。幸运的是，另一个人自愿了，这个人名叫纪尧姆-克雷蒂安·德·马尔泽布（Guillaume Chrétien de Malesherbes）。他是那种充满启蒙精神的自由主义的绝对化身。他是卢梭的朋友，与狄德罗有书信往来，曾在路易手下担任过
under Louis and he'd allowed Diderot to publish the encyclopedia which was kind of very radical, very atheist tinged, very keen botanist. And again, he is a bit like Baptiste. He's an example of how the whirly gig of politics is leaving one-time radicals behind and casting them as reactionaries. But he, unlike Baptiste, is prepared to come out and defend the king. So he's actually retired. He's 71. He's kind of very elderly. And he's the one who recruits Romand de Cés, the orotund guy who likes the sound of his own voice. There's also another distinguished lawyer called Francois Tanchet. So the three of them are appointed to defend the king and they have two weeks to prepare their case. And so they go to
国家书报检查官，并允许狄德罗出版那部非常激进、带有一点无神论色彩的百科全书。他也是个狂热的植物学家。同样，他有点像巴蒂斯特。他是政治风云如何将曾经的激进派抛在身后并将其打成反动派的一个例子。但他和巴蒂斯特不同，他准备站出来为国王辩护。所以他实际上已经退休了。他已经71岁了。他年纪非常大。正是他招募了罗曼·德·塞兹——那个喜欢自己声音洪亮的高大律师。还有另一位杰出的律师叫弗朗索瓦·唐谢（Francois Tanchet）。这三个人被指派为国王辩护，他们有两周时间来准备辩护案。于是他们前往
the cell in the temple where Louis is now being kept in isolation. So he's been separated from his family and they start preparing their defense. And it was with Malzurb that in 1788, Louis had discussed the trial of Charles the first, 1788. Yeah. Interesting. There are foundations there.
圣殿塔的牢房，路易目前正被单独关押在那里。他与家人分离了，他们开始准备辩护。正是在1788年，路易曾与马尔泽布讨论过查理一世的审判，1788年。是的。这其中是有基础的。
And of course, what Charles the first strategy in his trial had been to refuse to accept the legitimacy of the court. I mean, obviously, he had his head cut off, but he was always going to. But historians would generally say that that was very clever from Charles, because actually he was right. The court was illegitimate.
当然，查理一世在审判中的策略是拒绝接受法庭的合法性。我的意思是，很显然，他的头被砍了，但无论如何他都难逃一死。不过历史学家通常会说，查理这一招非常聪明，因为实际上他是对的。法庭是非法的。
And he basically said, come on, everyone knows this is a put up job and has no legal foundation. And he wasn't wrong. And he got a lot of sympathy for that. Right. And Mauserb, who's a very smart lawyer, very familiar with his English history, this is the strategy that he wants Louis to adopt, to insist on the wording of the original written constitution, which says that the king is inviolable, which in turn would be to attack the entire legitimacy of this second revolution that's happened over the course of 1792.
他基本上是在说：“得了吧，大家都知道这是一场内定审判，没有任何法律基础。”他说得没错。他也因此赢得了许多同情。没错。马尔泽布是一位非常精明的律师，对英国历史非常熟悉，这正是他希望路易采用的策略：坚持最初成文宪法的措辞——宪法规定国王不可侵犯，这反过来又等于攻击了1792年发生的所有这场第二次革命的整体合法性。
And this is exactly what the Montagnards had been afraid that they would do. The trial would become, it wouldn't just be a trial of Louis, it would be a trial of the new constitutional settlement. So throughout this history, we have discussed how whenever Louis is given an option, he always chooses the dumb option. And this is what he does again. He turns down Al Serbs advice. He says, no, I'm going to answer all these points that had been raised against him, all
而这正是山岳派一直害怕他们会做的事。审判将不仅是对路易的审判，还将是对新的宪法体制的审判。正如我们在整个历史中所讨论的那样，每当路易面临选择时，他总是选择最愚蠢的那一个。这次他又这么做了。他拒绝了马尔泽布的建议。他说：“不，我要回答所有针对我的指控，所有
the disparagements of his motivations and actions over the course of the previous year since the fall of the Bastille. He's obviously personally indignant about this and he wants to take them down. But of course it's madness because he has no prospect of convincing the court. He has no prospect of making a proper case. Malouser strategy is the only effective one. I think I suppose there are two interesting things there. So number one is, um, the weird thing is that answering point by end point is madness because on some of those points, he is clearly guilty.
关于我自巴士底狱陷落以来过去一年中动机和行为的贬低。”他对此显然感到个人的愤慨，并想要反驳他们。但这当然是疯狂的，因为他根本不可能说服法庭。他根本不可能组织起一个像样的辩护案。马尔泽布的策略才是唯一有效的。我想这其中有两件有趣的事。第一件是，奇怪的是，逐点反驳是疯狂的，因为在其中某些点上，他显然是有罪的。
Right. He did flight to Varenne. He did get in touch with the Austrians. He has been in touch with counter revolutionaries. He has been conspiring against the revolution. But the interesting thing is that in his own mind, clearly, Louis doesn't think he's guilty. He thinks these guys are bad people who have done a coup and have seized control of the revolution. Actually, I am blameless. I mean, that's the interesting thing. He wouldn't choose that strategy if he didn't have absolute confidence in his own
没错。他确实出逃去了瓦雷纳。他确实联系了奥地利人。他一直与反革命分子保持联系。他一直在策划反对革命。但有趣的是，在路易自己的心中，他显然不认为自己有罪。他认为这些人是坏人，他们发动了政变并夺取了革命的控制权。实际上我是无可指责的。我的意思是，这才是最有趣的地方。如果他对自己的无罪没有绝对的信心，他就不会选择这种策略。
innocence. And I think that's what explains, you what explains his serenity, absolute conviction that he's completely in the right, kind of a slight kind of Prince Andrew quality perhaps. Wow. You know, just madness. Anyway, he's the king. And so, well, he's not the king anymore, but as far as Malzahar is concerned, he is. So that's the strategy that they have to adopt. So again, this is
我认为正是这一点解释了——解释了为何他能如此平静，因为他绝对坚信自己完全正确，或许有点安德鲁王子那种特质吧。哇。简直是疯了。无论如何，他是国王。好吧，他不再是国王了，但在马尔泽布看来，他依然是。所以这就是他们必须采用的策略。因此，这也是
very Cromwellian. The date for the trial is set on the 26th of December, so the day after Christmas. So there's a kind of deliberate attempt to ignore the sacral quality of the feast day. So on Christmas day itself, Louis dictates his will to Malthus, suggesting that he knows what's going to happen. And then the following day, he's duly brought back to the convention and the trial happens. And this is when to say, he gives his famous speech. And you asked, does it persuade anyone of Louis innocence? Probably not. But does it persuade anyone that he should be spared execution?
非常克伦威尔式的。审判日期定在12月26日，也就是圣诞节的第二天。因此这其中有一种蓄意忽视节日神圣性的企图。所以在圣诞节当天，路易向马尔泽布口述了他的遗嘱，暗示他知道将会发生什么。接下来的几天里，他被按时带回国民公会接受审判。也就是在这个时候，正如所说，他发表了著名的演讲。你问，这有没有说服任何人相信路易是无罪的？可能没有。但它是否说服了任何人应该免除他的死刑？
Well, maybe it does because the convention are going to vote on whether Louis is guilty. And as you say, that's pretty much guaranteed he will be found guilty. But then they have to decide on a verdict. And in fact, they end up voting on a third point of principle because the gérons there, at the end of December, who clearly feel that the execution of the king will be seen as a kind of Montagnard triumph, they want to stop that happening. They propose that the verdict that the convention arrives at should be put to a referendum.
嗯，也许有，因为国民公会将投票表决路易是否有罪。正如你所说，他被判有罪几乎是板上钉钉的。但随后他们必须对判决结果做出决定。事实上，他们最终对第三个原则问题进行了投票，因为吉伦特派在12月底时，显然觉得对国王的处决会被视为山岳派的胜利，他们想阻止这种情况发生。他们提议将国民公会达成的判决提交给全民公投。
And this also has the additional benefit of enabling them to pose as the defenders of popular sovereignty. But in the long run, very bad move for the genre down this. I mean, and one of their own goals that they have been scoring for the last few months, right? That they keep coming up with these wheezes that don't quite work. Right. And which make them look royalist. I mean, that's the madness. None of them are royalist. Yeah, exactly.
这还有一个额外的好处，就是能让他们摆出一副大众主权捍卫者的姿态。但从长远来看，这对吉伦特派来说是一个极其糟糕的举动。我的意思是，这是他们过去几个月里一直在自摆乌龙的一幕，对吧？他们不断想出这些不太管用的歪主意。没错。这让他们看起来像保王党。我的意思是，这就是疯狂之处。他们当中没有一个人是保王党。没错，确实如此。
So the Montagnards, you know, they're very indignant at this. They regard it as terrible. And out on the streets of Paris, the soncolote also are appalled by the idea that Louis' fate should be protracted. So on the 30th of December, delegates from about 18 of the sections in Paris, so these are the kind of the local councils in Paris, petition the convention for the tyrant to be put to death immediately. And it's full melodrama. They've got women who are carrying the bloody clothes of relatives who died on that day. They've got people who are kind of hobbling in on crutches after they'd been shot in or stabbed in the leg by the Swiss guards. It's all absolutely
因此，山岳派对此感到非常愤怒。他们认为这太可怕了。在巴黎街头，无套裤汉也对路易的命运被拖延感到震惊。因此在12月30日，来自巴黎大约18个区（也就是巴黎的基层委员会）的代表向国民公会请愿，要求立即处决这个暴君。这是一场彻底的 melodrama（情节剧）。他们有妇女带着在那天死去的亲人的血衣；有些人一瘸一拐地拄着拐杖走进来，他们的腿在不久前被瑞士卫队开枪击中或刺伤。这一切绝对是
calculated to target the heartstrings of upstanding patriots. And then just when it seems that things can't get any worse for the Girondins, there's another bombshell because early in January, letters are produced showing that three of them, three leading Girondins, had been corresponding with the King in the days building up to the massacre on the 10th of August, the attack on the Tuileries. At that point, some of them are hoping he might bring them back into his ministry and that they wouldn't have to have this kind of coup. Yeah, and their claim is, which I'm sure is absolutely genuine, is that they'd been communicating
精心计算好要触动正直爱国者心弦的。正当吉伦特派的情况似乎不能再糟的时候，又一颗重磅炸弹落下了：1月上旬，有信件被出示，显示其中三名吉伦特派领袖曾在8月10日大屠杀（即攻击杜伊勒里宫）发生前的几天里与国王保持书信往来。当时其中一些人希望国王能把他们重新召回内阁，这样他们就不用经历这种政变了。是的，他们的说法——我确信绝对是真诚的——是他们与国王通信是因为他们急于拯救祖国，因为那是普鲁士人推进、一切似乎都陷入灾难状态的时期。但很显然，这至少给他们打上了缺乏对爱国军队英勇作战信心的烙印。所以这观感很不好。而且情况特别糟糕，因为正如你在上一期节目中提到的，国王和王妃与米拉波之间的书信是从国王的保险箱里搜出来的。因此这种感觉——无论你看到哪里，到处都是叛国与背叛，而爱国主义的面具下隐藏着最极端的叛国。
with the king because they were anxious to save the fatherland, because this was the period when the Prussians were advancing and everything seemed in a state of disaster. But obviously, this brands them at the very least as lacking in confidence in the martial prowess of the patriotic armies. So that's a bad look. And of course it's particularly bad because you mentioned in the previous episode that the correspondence between the king and queen and Mirabeau had been produced from the king's safe. And so this sense that everywhere you look, there is treason and treachery and the mask of patriotism is hiding rankest treason.
这对吉伦特派来说同样糟糕，这让他们看起来像是暗中同情保王党的隐秘分子。这对山岳派来说是个大好消息。所有这一切意味着，在1月15日，国民公会准备进行这三项投票。他是否有罪？判决是否应该提交公投？如果他有罪，刑罚应该是什么？因此第一项动议是：路易·卡佩有罪还是无罪？马拉提出了这项获得通过的动议，即投票应该是公开的，这样任何叛徒都无法在秘密中行事。不出所料，压倒性的绝对多数通过了，没有人投无罪票，
This again is terrible for the Girondins and it makes them seem like kind of closet royalists. So very good news for the Montagnard. So all of which means that on the 15th of January, the convention is ready to have these three votes. Is he guilty? Should the verdict go to a referendum? If he is guilty, what should the sentence be? So the first motion is Louis Capet guilty or not guilty? Mara has introduced the motion which is passed that the vote should be public so that no traitors can practice behind kind of secrecy. And surprise surprise, a universal absolute majority, nobody votes against the guilty
尽管有26票弃权。确实有26票弃权。是的，有26票弃权。因此他理所当然地被判有罪。接下来是关于是否应提交公投的投票，结果以425票对286票被否决。这对吉伦特派来说是一个极其尴尬的失败。然后是关于路易的惩罚应该是什么的投票。这是一场绝对的马拉松式会议。
verdict. Although there are 26 abstentions. There are 26 abstentions. Yes, there are 26 abstentions. So he is duly found guilty. Then there's a vote on should it go to a referendum and this is defeated 425 to 286. So that is a very embarrassing defeat for the Girondins. And then there's the vote on what Louis's punishment should be. And this is an absolutely marathon session.
它持续了24个小时以上。每一位议员都必须走上审判台，说出他认为应该判处的刑罚。他们被允许解释他们做出这一决定的原因。有些像播客风格一样滔滔不绝讲上几个小时？其他人则给出了更简洁的总结，并做出了各种判决。显而易见的判决是死刑。山岳派对此极为热衷。他们认为这是一个绝妙的主意，因此他们非常
It lasts for over 24 hours. Every deputy has to go up to the tribunal, has to say what he thinks the verdict should be. They are allowed to explain why they have arrived at their decision. Some podcast style, do you go on for hours and hours? Others give slightly more concise summaries and various decisions are given. So the obvious one is death. The Montagnards are all over this. They think this is a great idea. So they're very
热切。毫无疑问，发表最响亮、最具罗马风格解释的人是罗伯斯庇尔。“在压迫者面前我是冷酷无情的，”他宣称，“因为我对受压迫者充满同情。我不承认那种屠杀人民却宽恕专制君主的人性。”这就是那个曾经坚决反对死刑的人如何为死刑辩护的方式。他基本上是在说：“我投死刑是因为我太善良了。”他满腔热忱，全心全意。多米尼克，投票支持死刑的最令人震惊的人物是谁？故事里最坏的家伙。那是谁？这就是平等派菲利普（Philippe Equality），也就是国王自己的堂兄。他真是个可怕的家伙。我的意思是，至少弃权或者建议流放之类的好歹也行。但为了你自己的堂兄而这样彻底倒向死刑，我认为
keen. It is Robespierre, unsurprisingly, who gives the most ringing and kind of Roman explanation for it. I am inflexible in relation to impressors, he declares, because I am compassionate towards the oppressed. I do not recognize the humanity that butchers the people and pardons despots. So this is how the man who had been very much against the death penalty justifies it. I vote for death because I'm so kind is basically what he's saying. He's all about heart, all heart. And Dominic, the most startling person to vote for the death penalty. The worst man in the story. Who's that? This is Philippe Equality, Philip Equality, who is the king's own cousin. What a terrible man he is. I mean, at least abstain or at least say exile or something like that. But to go all in in this way for your own cousin, I think
这是非常非常糟糕的行为。甚至有人投票支持死刑并附带建议对国王予以特赦，因为有些人就是这么投的——死刑然后特赦。是的。其他人则投票赞成流放。这通常是出于地缘政治原因提出的建议，即应该将国王当作人质，然后当与敌对强权谈判达成和平条款时，也许可以把他流放出去。对此，路易-塞巴斯蒂安·梅谢（Louis Sebastien Mercier）——那位剧作家、奥兰普·德古热的朋友——提出了一个精彩的卢梭式的反转解读。
is very, very bad behavior. Even death with a recommendation that the King be reprieved, because that is what some people vote for. So death and then a pardon. Yeah. Yeah. Others vote for exile. And this is a generally proposed for geopolitical reasons that the King should be kept as a hostage. And then when peace terms have been negotiated with the kind of hostile powers, then perhaps he can be sent off into exile. There is a brilliant spin, a Rousseauist spin on this from Louis Sebastien Mercier, who we've been the playwright, he was a friend of Olymp de Gouges, who in the
是非常、非常糟糕的行为。甚至有人建议判处死刑并附带请求国王获得特赦，因为这就是一些人的投票主张。所以先判死刑，然后赦免。是的。是的。另一些人则投票主张流放。这通常是出于地缘政治的原因，即应该把国王作为人质扣留。然后，当与敌对势力谈判好和平条款后，也许就可以把他流放出去。戏剧家路易-塞巴斯蒂安·梅尔西埃对此有一个精妙的解读，一个卢梭式的解读，他是奥兰普·德古热的朋友，他在
long run will become a counter-revolutionary, but he's a delegate in the convention. And he proposes that the royal family be transported to Tahiti or some other island in the south so that contact with nature in the simplicity of a fishing hut would rehabilitate them. People would pay good money for that these days. It's a brilliant idea. Marie Antoinette would love that, wouldn't she?
从长远来看，他会变成一个反革命分子，但他是国民公会的代表。他建议把王室成员送到塔希提岛或南方的某个小岛上，这样让他们在大自然的怀抱中、在简陋的渔民小屋里过着简单生活，就能使他们改过自新。如今人们愿意花大价钱买这种体验。这真是个绝妙的主意。玛丽·安托瓦内特一定会喜欢这个，对吧？
That's a very, that's a honeymoon holiday. A Tahitian maiden. She could do fishing and surfing like Joseph Banks. It would be great. And Mercier is one of several delegates who say that he's found it very difficult weighing up the pros and cons has made him physically ill. Huge stress. There are other people who vote, a minority who vote for kind of life imprisonment
这绝对是一场度蜜月的假期。一个塔希提少女。她可以像约瑟夫·班克斯那样钓鱼和冲浪。那太棒了。梅西耶是几位表示自己觉得权衡利弊极其艰难的代表之一，这甚至让他急出了病。压力巨大。还有其他人投票，少数人投票支持某种终身监禁
under in irons or under very strict surveillance, which of course would have made Louis the 16th, the second member of the royal family after the man in the iron mask. Of course. Yeah. Such a fate. Very good. And then there are a couple of people suggest that Louis should be sent to the galleys. Like Jean Valjean. Like Jean Valjean in Les Miserables. So one of them is a very hardcore Republican called Joseph Marie Le Quignot, who is from
戴着镣铐或者在极其严格的监视下，当然，这会使路易十六成为继铁面人之后王室家族的第二个成员。当然。是的。真是这样的命运。非常好。还有几个人建议把路易流放到苦役船上。就像冉阿让一样。就像《悲惨世界》里的冉阿让一样。其中一人是一个非常强硬的共和党人，名叫约瑟夫·玛丽·勒基尼奥，他来自
Brittany a lawyer inevitably. The reason he argues for it is that he says that this will be a punishment much worse than death because of course it's a living hell. And Louis has to be said doesn't seem the kind of man whose physique would lend itself to a lot of strenuous rowing. And then there's Condor Say, you know, this great enthusiast, very man of compassion who is opposed on principle to the death penalty. And this is why he votes because he says that he disapproves of the death penalty and going to the galleys is, you know, if you're not even killed, then you get sent to the galleys. Anyway, so these
布列塔尼，不可避免地是一名律师。他主张这一惩罚的理由是，他说这将是一种比死刑还要糟糕得多的惩罚，因为这无疑是人间炼狱。而且必须承认，路易看起来并不像是那种体格适合进行大量费力划船的人。接着是孔多塞，你知道的，这位伟大的狂热支持者、充满同情心的人，他在原则上反对死刑。这就是他投票的原因，因为他说他反对死刑，而流放苦役船，你知道的，如果你甚至没被处死，那你就会被送去苦役船。不管怎样，这些
are all the various options. The vote concludes on the evening of the 17th of January and the tally is actually incredibly close and the King is sentenced to death by one vote. One vote. It's more if you throw in the, if you include the number of people who've recommended, who voted for death but recommended that he be pardoned. Yeah. And that is kind of tallied. I mean, madly, the Girondins that they call for reprieve,
就是各种各样的选项。投票于1月17日傍晚结束，计票结果实际上非常接近，国王以一票之差被判处死刑。一票之差。如果你把那些建议死刑但同时建议予以特赦的人数算进去，票数还要多一些。是的。而且这个票数被统计了进来。我是说，吉伦特派疯狂地呼吁暂缓执行，
they asked for another roll call vote. I mean, absolute madness. And that again is rejected. So the final verdict is delivered three o'clock on the morning of the 18th of January. Dawn is a few hours off and it's bad for the Girondins because they now again, they've kind of confirmed this sense among the Montagnards that they're closet royalists. But of course the person it's really bad for is the erstwhile King, Louis Capet. And so his lawyers who have been standing the whole way through this way, they haven't been given chairs.
他们要求进行另一次唱名表决。我的天，这简直是绝对的疯狂。而这再次遭到拒绝。因此，最终裁决在1月18日凌晨三点宣布。离黎明只有几个小时了，这对吉伦特派来说很糟糕，因为他们现在再次向山岳派印证了那种“他们是隐蔽保王派”的感觉。但当然，真正倒霉的是昔日国王路易·卡佩。所以他的律师们从头到尾一直站着，他们没有被分配到椅子。
So it may be that, um, uh, you know, some justification, um, anyway, they are allowed to give their response to the verdict and Malzahar, who's a famous orator gets to the tribunal, tries to give his talk, can't, breaks down in tears. This is a tremendous display of sensibility. Everyone else is in tears. It's very Rousseau. And he then goes from the convention to the temple. He is led into the presence of the convicted criminal, Louis Capay.
所以这可能是，嗯，呃，你知道的，某种辩解，无论如何，他们被允许对判决做出回应，著名的演说家马尔代布走上法庭，试图发表他的演讲，却无法继续，放声痛哭。这展现了极大的感伤。其他所有人都哭了。这非常卢梭。然后他从国民公会前往圣殿。他被带到了被定罪的罪犯路易·卡佩面前。
Yeah. Again, he tries to tell Louis what's happened again. He dissolves into tears. He falls at Louis' feet and it's at Louis' feet that he announces the verdict of the convention. Death. Well, what a moving scene and actually I'm embarrassed, but moved to report to the listeners that Tom actually can't continue because he too has dissolved into tears.
是的。同样，他试图再次将发生的事情告诉路易，他又一次情绪崩溃，泪流满面。他倒在了路易的脚下，正是在路易的脚下，他宣读了国民公会的判决：死刑。噢，多么感人的场面啊，其实我很不好意思，但又很动容地向听众们报告，汤姆实际上无法继续下去了，因为他也情绪崩溃，泪流满面。
So we're going to have to take a break and we'll return after the break when Tom has regained his composure to tell you about Louis' fate. to tell you about Louis' fate. This episode is brought to you by Vanguard. Throughout history, people have always looked for ways to make life easier. Just think about the Romans. They built aqueducts to bring water straight to their cities so they didn't have to haul it themselves. Well, Dominic, think of all the books that we use when we're reading to research topics on the rest is history. Imagine if those books could only be produced by monks spending months, maybe years toiling
所以我们要休息一下，等汤姆恢复平静后，我们会在休息回来后向你们讲述路易的命运。向你们讲述路易的命运。本集节目由Vanguard为您呈献。纵观历史，人们总是在寻找让生活更轻松的方法。想想罗马人就知道了。他们建造了引水渠，把水直接引到他们的城市，这样他们就不必自己去运水了。那么，多米尼克，想想我们在为《历史其余部分》研究课题而阅读时所使用的所有书籍。想象一下，如果这些书籍只能由僧侣们花费几个月甚至几年的时间在羊皮纸上辛苦劳作才能生产出来。
over vellum. And today, managing your investments can be just as simple. With Vanguard's managed ISA, their experts handle the investing for you. So, if you've been putting off sorting your ISA or if you're new to investing, Vanguard's managed ISA makes it simple. Life is often hectic and figuring out investments can be overwhelming. But with Vanguard, you don't have to do it alone. They will help you work out your risk appetite. They'll match you to an investment plan that is right for you and then they'll do the rest. I mean imagine if you'd been a king
而今天，管理你的投资也可以如此简单。通过Vanguard托管的个人储蓄账户（ISA），他们的专家会为你处理投资。所以，如果你一直拖延着没有整理你的ISA，或者你是投资新手，Vanguard的托管ISA能让这一切变得简单。生活往往忙碌不堪，弄懂投资可能会让人不知所措。但有了Vanguard，你就不必孤军奋战。他们会帮你弄清你的风险承受能力。他们会为你匹配适合你的投资计划，然后剩下的事情就交由他们来做。我是说，想象一下如果你曾是一位国王，
and you had to spend the whole time working out your investment plans. What opportunities then for invading France? So if Vanguard's sorting out your ISA, what will you do? Discover managed ISA today. When investing, your capital is at risk. Tax rules apply. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. The good news is that Tom has dried his tears. The bad news is that Louis Capet is facing an appointment with Madame Guillotine. So Tom, we ended with Malzheb's sobbing, announced the verdict to Louis, and then the convention themselves sent a delegation to Louis, don't they, to sort of formally read the verdict to him. So that's three days after the trial.
而你不得不把所有时间都用来制定投资计划。那还有什么机会去侵略法国呢？所以，如果Vanguard帮你在整理你的ISA，你会做什么呢？立即了解托管ISA。投资有风险。税收规则适用。欢迎回到《历史其余部分》。好消息是，汤姆已经擦干了眼泪。坏消息是，路易·卡佩即将面临与断头台Madame Guillotine的会面。所以，汤姆，我们刚才说到马尔代布啜泣着向路易宣布了判决，然后国民公会本身也派了一个代表团去见路易，对吧，去向他正式宣读判决。所以那是在审判的三天后。
And he remarkably still is very composed and indeed serene when he receives them. Yeah, everyone comments on this, that almost from the moment he's brought to trial, he does maintain this kind of incredible display of sans-fois, I guess is the only word for it. So the delegation from the convention come to see him on the afternoon of the 20th of January. So that's a Sunday and they arrive early afternoon at two o'clock and the delegation includes Jacques Hebert, who is the guy who's always writing abusive pamphlets and so on, coming up with the kind of Trumpian nicknames for his enemies.
而令人惊奇的是，当他接待他们时，他仍然非常镇定，甚至十分安详。是的，所有人都对此进行了评论，几乎从他被送上审判的那一刻起，他就一直保持着这种不可思议的冷静，我猜唯一的词就是冷静（sans-froid）。因此，国民公会的代表团在1月20日下午来看望他。那是一个星期天，他们在下午早些时候两点钟到达，代表团成员包括雅克·埃贝尔，也就是那个总是写辱骂性小册子之类的人，为他的敌人起一些川普式的绰号。
And the Minister of Justice, who is a man called Joseph Carrin, and they come into the into Louis Selle and they read out the sentence of the court to him. And Louis has prepared a list, written list of three requests. So the first of these, he asks, a delay of three days to be able to prepare myself to appear in the presence of God. This is rejected. He's told he is going to be executed in the morning, say on the 21st of January. Then he requests freedom for his family. And you said how when he was with them for the four months of his imprisonment before the trial start, he had been living like a kind of middle-class family under COVID with a, you know, a garden, homeschooling, all that kind of thing.
还有司法大臣，一个名叫约瑟夫·加兰的人，他们走进路易的牢房，向他宣读了法院的判决。路易准备了一份手写的三个请求清单。首先，他请求宽限三天时间，以便让自己能够准备好出现在上帝面前。这个请求被拒绝了。他被告知他将在早晨被处决，也就是1月21日。然后他请求还他家人自由。正如你所说，在审判开始前的四个月监禁期间，他和家人住在一起，就像疫情期间的中产阶级家庭一样，有花园、在家上学，诸如此类的事情。
So I guess he's had a kind of last experience as the family man that I think he always was at heart. So he's had that, but now he wants to make sure that they will be set free. They will not be set free. So this request too will be rejected, but he is told by Gara, I mean, Gara doesn't dash his hopes at that point. So he says that the nation always magnanimous, always just will consider your family's fate. So Louis can go to the guillotine, hoping at least that he's secured the possibility of liberty for his family. One kind of sub request to that though is granted, which is that Louis will be allowed to see his family for one last time. So as we said, they've
所以我想他最后体验了一把顾家男人的生活，而他内心深处一直都是这样的人。所以他经历过了，但现在他想确保他的家人能够重获自由。他们不会获得自由。所以这个请求也将被拒绝，但加兰告诉路易——我是说，加兰当时并没有彻底粉碎他的希望——他说，宽宏大量、一向公正的国民将考虑你家人的命运。所以路易可以走向断头台，至少怀揣着为家人争取到自由可能性的希望。不过其中一个小请求得到了批准，那就是路易将被允许最后一次见他的家人。正如我们所说，他们已经被
been separated. And then his third request is also granted, and this is to hear confession from a priest who has maintained his independence from the kind of the Republican church that's been set up. So a non-juring priest, as they're called, one who hasn't sworn the oath of loyalty to the Republic. And so, Louis has had a recommendation from his sister, Madame Elisabeth, who is imprisoned in the temple with him. And this amazing is an Irishman. It's a guy called Henry Essex Edgeworth, who is the son of an Irish convert and is related to Maria Edgeworth.
分开了。接着他的第三个请求也得到了批准，那就是听取一位与已经建立的共和教会保持独立的牧师的忏悔。也就是所谓的非宣誓牧师，即没有向共和国宣誓效忠的牧师。因此，路易得到了他的妹妹伊丽莎白夫人的推荐，她和路易一起被关押在圣殿里。令人惊奇的是，这个人是个爱尔兰人。他叫亨利·埃塞克斯·埃奇沃思，是一位爱尔兰皈依者的儿子，与玛丽亚·埃奇沃思有亲戚关系。
The novelist, yeah. Yeah, so he'd been the son of a Church of Ireland priest who had converted to Catholicism when Henry was four and they'd moved to France. And Edgeworth had been brought up by the Jesuits in Toulouse. He'd become a priest, he'd become l'abbé de Firmont and he had become Madame Elizabeth's confessor in 1791. And he's very respected even by the kind of the son-culottes, by the revolutionary leaders. He's admired. And so he is allowed access to the king, or the ex-king, I should say.
也就是那位小说家，是的。是的，所以他是爱尔兰教会一位牧师的儿子，当亨利四岁时，这位牧师皈依了天主教，然后他们搬到了法国。埃奇沃思在图卢兹由耶稣会士抚养长大。他成了一名神父，成为了费尔蒙神父（l'abbé de Firmont），并在1791年成为了伊丽莎白夫人的神父。甚至连无套裤汉、革命领袖们都非常尊敬他。他备受推崇。因此，他被允许会见国王，或者说前国王，我应该这么说。
And he arrives at the temple that evening at seven o'clock. And from this point on, he will stay with the king until the very point of his execution. So an hour after the Abbe de Firmont has arrived, Louis' family are brought into his presence. So that's Marie Antoinette, the D dauphin, his son, his daughter, Madame Royale and his sister, Madame Elisabeth. And they're taken into the cell and although the guards keep watch, they can't hear what is said. And the best account we have of this comes from the man who's been serving Louis as his valet, he's a man called Jean Baptiste Clery. And he had been appointed to the role of Valet by the municipality of Paris.
他在那天晚上七点到达了圣殿。从这一刻起，他将一直陪伴着国王，直到国王被处决的那一刻。在费尔蒙神父到达一小时后，路易的家人被带到了他的面前。也就是玛丽·安托瓦内特、王太子（他的儿子）、他的女儿（玛丽-泰蕾兹公主）以及他的妹妹伊丽莎白夫人。他们被带进牢房，尽管守卫在一旁监视，但他们听不到谈话内容。我们关于这次会面最好的记录来自于一直担任路易贴身男仆的人，他叫让-巴蒂斯特·克雷。他被巴黎市政府任命为男仆。
He's a Republican, he's a revolutionary, but over the course of his term of service, he has basically been turned. He comes to admire and respect Louis for his serene behavior, for his sang-froid, for his stiff upper lip. And in due course, he comes to write a very favourable account of Louis' last months and days and hours. And he says of this meeting, this last meeting between Louis and his family, it was impossible to hear anything. One only saw that after each phrase of the king, the sobs of the princesses redoubled and that then the king began again to speak. It was easy to judge from their movements that he himself had told them of his condemnation. And they're together for two hours and they can't bear to be parted. And in the end, it's Louis himself who says,
他是个共和派，是个革命者，但在他的任职期间，他基本上被感化了。他开始钦佩并尊敬路易的镇定行为、他的冷静、他的坚忍不拔。随后，他写了一份非常有利于路易最后几个月、几天和几小时的记录。他这样描述这次会面，即路易和家人们的最后一次会面：“根本听不清任何声音。人们只能看到，在国王每说一句话之后，公主们的啜泣声就会加倍，然后国王又开始说话。从他们的举动很容易判断出，他自己已经把他的死刑判决告诉了他们。”他们在一起呆了两个小时，难分难舍。最后，路易自己说道：
look, don't worry, you can see me again tomorrow morning before I go to the guillotine. And this is a lie, but it's designed to get them out of the cell in a mood of hope. But as the family are being ushered out, his daughter, the princess Royal bursts into floods of tears, hugs her father collapses in a dead faint and the family all gather around, bring her back. Uh, and, and this is the last time that they, they spend time together. And she's a teenager, isn't she? She's what 15 or so.
“听着，别担心，明天早上我去断头台之前，你们还能再见到我。”这是一个谎言，但其目的是让他们带着希望的心情离开牢房。但当家人们被引出时，他的女儿，王室公主突然放声大哭，拥抱父亲并当场昏厥过去，家人们纷纷围上来救醒她。呃，这是他们最后一次共度时光。她还是个青少年，对吧？她大约15岁左右。
Yeah. So that's that. That's the last time that they are together. Meanwhile, the king is not the only person who has been hanging out with a priest because someone else has been receiving absolution. And this is someone that we mentioned in our last series. It's the man who will be operating the guillotine and executing the king the next morning.
是的，就是这样。那是他们最后一次聚在一起。与此同时，国王并不是唯一一个与神父待在一起的人，因为还有另一个人正在接受赦免。而这个人我们在上一系列中提到过。他就是将要操作断头台并在第二天早晨处决国王的人。
And this is Henri Sanson, the man who had been the royal executioner and who is, I guess, a kind of living link between the Ancien Régime and the new world that the revolution has ushered in. Because he's part of a, he's the sixth generation, I think, of Sansons who've been executioners, isn't he? Yes. And we did an episode on how all the kind of the weirdness surrounding executions
这个人就是亨利·桑松，曾担任王室刽子手的人，我猜他算是旧制度与革命开创新世界之间活生生的纽带。因为他是桑松家族第六代刽子手，我没记错吧？是的。我们做过一集节目，讲述了围绕处决的所有诡异氛围
and indeed the role of the executioner had been systematically got rid of by the Republican legislators. So Sanson, who had been the sinister figure in scarlet robes, who could just walk through marketplaces and grab whatever he wanted and wasn't allowed to go to theaters and things. He's now a state functionary and the emphasis is on the rational, the mechanical, the everyday. And so it's been decided that the King will be executed like any other criminal now in France by the guillotine. Yeah.
以及刽子手的角色是如何被共和派立法者系统性地革除的。因此，桑松这个身穿红色长袍、可以在集市上随意走动并拿走他想要的任何东西、还不被允许去剧院等场所的阴暗人物，现在成了一名国家官员，其重点变成了理性、机械和日常。因此，人们决定国王现在将在法国像其他任何罪犯一样被断头台处决。是的。
And because they want a stage suitable for the execution of a former king, they fix on the largest open square in the whole of Paris, which is what today is the Place de la Concorde, but had originally been the Place Louis XV, so there'd been a huge statue of Louis XV on a pedestal that had been removed back in August 1792, so the pedestal is now empty. And actually, in due course, a large statue of Liberty will be set up on it. It's also next to the Tuileries, so there's a kind of symbolic resonance there as well, because the Tuileries is seen as, you know, this place where the blood of citizens have been spilled on the orders of the tyrant. So it's fitting that he be put to death within eyesight of
而且因为他们想要一个适合处决前国王的舞台，他们选中了整个巴黎最大的露天广场，也就是今天的协和广场，但最初被称为路易十五广场。路易十五的巨型雕像曾立在底座上，但在1792年8月已被拆除，所以底座现在是空的。事实上，假以时日，一座巨大的自由女神像将被竖立在上面。它也紧邻杜伊勒里宫，因此这里也有一种象征性的共鸣，因为杜伊勒里宫被视为，你知道的，这个地方曾因暴君的命令而流淌着公民的鲜血。所以把他处死在能够看到它的地方是非常合适的。
it. And the Place Louis-Cans has been renamed the Place de la Révolution. Symbolically, it works on pretty much every level. And so the guillotine is brought there. It's set up in the middle of it. And Sansa, you know, he checks the hinges. He gets out the oil, makes sure the blade is properly weighted, sharpens it. And the whole point is the death is something kind of Republican, something progressive, clean and modern, clean and modern. So not appropriate to the dispatch, not just of a king, but of monarchy itself. Yeah. So the
路易十五广场已被更名为革命广场。从象征意义上讲，它在几乎所有层面上都起作用。于是断头台被搬到了那里。它被竖立在广场中央。桑松检查了铰链。他拿出油，确保刀刃的重量合适，并将其磨锋利。这一切的重点在于，死亡是一种共和式的、进步的、干净且现代的事情，干净且现代。因此，这不仅适合发落一个国王，更适合发落君主制本身。是的。所以，
day dawns and massive preparations have been made. So armed men, soldiers, members of the National Guard have been ordered to line the entire route from the temple to the Place de la Révolution to make sure that the crowds are kept back and more importantly that royalists can't kind of try and make an attempt to rescue the king or anything like that. Again this is very Charles I in Whitehall, isn't it? Absolutely the same scenario. One thing that isn't like Charles I though, where members of the general public
黎明破晓，大规模的筹备工作已经就绪。武装人员、士兵、国民自卫队成员奉命排成两行，沿着从圣殿到革命广场的整条路线列队，以确保人群被隔离在后面，更重要的是防止保王派试图营救国王或进行类似尝试。这非常像白金汉宫外的查理一世，对吧？完全是相同的场景。不过有一点不像查理一世，在查理一世的处决中，普通公众
were allowed to watch the execution in the Place de la Révolution, it's only soldiers. So there are only armed men, about 80,000 of them. There are 84 pieces of artillery. So the people there, they're armed and they're complete revolutionaries. They're complete Republicans. There's no doubt about that. If the guillotine doesn't work, they can turn their cannons on him. Exactly, blast him to pieces. So orders are issued that anyone who cries out for the king to be pardoned or who gives any manifestation of royalist sympathy at all will be arrested and imprisoned. Because the delegates to the convention, they're worried about the natural compassion of the
被允许在革命广场观看处决，而这里只有士兵。所以只有武装人员，大约有8万名。有84门火炮。因此在那里的人都是武装人员，而且是彻头彻尾的革命者。他们是坚定的共和党人。毫无疑问。如果断头台不起作用，他们可以用大炮轰击他。没错，把他炸成碎片。因此下达了命令：任何高呼要求宽恕国王或表现出任何保王主义同情的人都将被逮捕和监禁。因为国民公会的代表们担心
feminine. They're worried that women are more prone to displays of sympathy than men. A decree is ordered that all women should stay in their homes. They're not allowed out to watch the display and execution. All houses are ordered to be shuttered. So again, people can't lean out and kind of watch the passing display. And the mayor of Paris has a very stentorian notice plastered across the walls of the city so that everyone can read it. The sword of the law, this notice declares, will strike
女性天然的同情心。他们担心女性比男性更容易表现出同情。下达了一项法令，规定所有女性都应呆在家里。她们不允许出门观看这场展示和处决。所有房屋都被命令关上百叶窗。同样，人们也不能探出头去观看路过的景象。巴黎市长在城市的墙壁上张贴了一张非常严厉的公告，以便所有人都能读到。公告宣告：法律之剑，
the greatest and the guiltiest of conspirators. You have, citizens of Paris, during the course of this long trial, maintained the calm that is suitable for free men. You will know how to preserve it at the instant of the execution of the tyrant. You will prove by the decorum of your behaviour that an act of justice in no way resembles vengeance. That day will be for kings and for peoples at once a memorable example of the just punishment of despots and of the mournful dignity that a sovereign people must keep in the exercise of its power. And the thing is people in the revolution just cannot stop talking like that. That's true. Yeah.
将打击最大、最罪大恶极的阴谋家。巴黎的市民们，在这个漫长的审判过程中，你们保持了自由人所应有的冷静。在暴君被处决的那一刻，你们将懂得如何保持这种冷静。你们将用行为的仪态证明，正义的行为绝不类似于复仇。对于国王和人民来说，那一天将同时是一个具有纪念意义的模范：既是对专制者的正义惩罚，也是主权人民在行使其权力时必须保持的哀伤尊严。”问题是，革命中的人们就是忍不住用这种腔调说话。确实如此。是的。
All speeches, all public proclamations, they all sound like they've been lifted from a school book of Latin prose. Yeah, they do, don't they? Well, they're doing it deliberately. That's how they think a revolutionary should write. So early hours of the morning, the streets of Paris are sounding to the rumble of the artillery being taken into the Place de la Révolution. You hear the clopping of hooves, of the cavalry riding to take up place, the tread of soldiers taking up their positions.
所有的演讲，所有的公开宣言，听起来都像是从拉丁文散文学校课本里抄出来的。是的，确实如此，不是吗？嗯，他们是故意这么做的。他们认为革命者就该这么写作。因此，清晨时分，巴黎的街道上回荡着火炮被运往革命广场的隆隆声。你能听到马蹄声、骑兵前往指定地点的马蹄声、士兵就位的脚步声。
Five a.m., Sanson, the executioner, is wakened by his assistant so that he can go again, you know, check all the mechanics and everything. He doesn't want it to go wrong. And at the same time in the temple, 5 o'clock, Louis is wakened by Clary, his valet, who shaves him. 6am, Louis' last confession with the Abbe de Firmont, his confessor. He has not eaten the night before. He doesn't eat now because the last rites are accompanied by fasting. At 7am, he is dressed by Clary. He wears, we're told, a fresh shirt, a white waistcoat, grey trousers, a light jacket.
早上5点，刽子手桑松被他的助手叫醒，以便他能再次去检查所有的机械装置等等。他可不想出什么岔子。与此同时，在圣殿里，5点整，路易被他的男仆克雷叫醒，克雷给他刮了胡子。早上6点，路易与他的神父费尔蒙神父进行最后的忏悔。他前一天晚上没有吃东西，现在也不吃，因为最后的宗教仪式伴随着斋戒。早上7点，克雷为他穿衣。我们被告知，他穿了一件新衬衫、一件白色马甲、灰色长裤、一件浅色夹克。
And Louis takes off his wedding ring to be given to Marie Antoinette. And he has a royal seal which he's taken from his watch, so that hadn't been confiscated and this is to be given to Marie Antoinette. And he has a royal seal, which he's taken from his watch. So that hadn't been confiscated. And this is to be given to his son. And his son, of course, before the morning is out, will become, if you are a royalist, Louis XVII. 745, a delegation from the city of Paris arrives. They're accompanied by 14 soldiers. They stand to attention in two rows outside Louis' cell. Louis asks for permission for Clary to cut his hair at the nape of his neck because he doesn't want the humiliation of having Sansan, the executioner, do it, which is something of course that Sansan has done many, many times over the course of his career.
路易脱下他的结婚戒指，交给玛丽·安托瓦内特。他还带着一个从手表上取下来的皇家印章，这个印章没有被没收，将交由玛丽·安托瓦内特。他还带着一个从手表上取下来的皇家印章，这没有被没收。这个要交给他的儿子。而他的儿子，当然，在这个早晨结束之前，如果你是保王派的话，将成为路易十七。7点45分，巴黎市的一个代表团到达。他们由14名士兵陪同。他们在路易的牢房外立正站成两排。路易请求允许克雷剪掉他后颈的头发，因为他不想经受由刽子手桑松来理发的屈辱，当然，这是桑松在他的职业生涯中做过无数次的事情。
But this is denied him. He is a common criminal. He is going to be treated like a common criminal. Louis then kneels down. He's blessed by the Abbey. They then stand around. It's a bit of embarrassment. Nobody's quite sure what to do.
但这遭到拒绝。他是一个普通罪犯。他将受到普通罪犯的对待。路易随后跪下。他得到了神父的祝福。然后他们站在周围。这有点尴尬。没人太清楚该做些什么。
So Louis then says, Paton, you know, let's head off. Let's go. They go outside. It's very cold. There's a fog everywhere. So hard to see through the gloom out in the streets, piles of snow so that people can get by along the road. I said that Louis is to be treated like a common criminal.
于是路易说：“走吧，你知道的，我们出发吧。我们走。”他们走到外面。天气非常冷。到处都是雾。昏暗中很难看清街上的情景，路边堆着雪，以便人们能沿着路走。我刚才说路易将被当作普通罪犯对待。
There is one exception to this and that is that he is given a coach so he's not put in the tumbril in the open cart. And the reason for that is basically security. If he's in the coach, it's much easier to guard him. And the coach has been provided by Gareth, the minister of justice. It's a great bottle green thing, although not as large as the coach that... Not the Varenne super coach. The Varenne, the Varenne wasp like coach that they take into Varenne. So Louis gets into
这里有一个例外，那就是他得到了一辆马车，所以他没有被塞进开放式的囚车里。这样做的原因基本上是出于安全考虑。如果他在马车里，监视他会容易得多。这辆马车是由司法大臣加兰提供的。这是一辆巨大的瓶绿色马车，尽管没有……没有瓦雷讷超级马车那么大。瓦雷讷，瓦雷讷那辆像黄蜂一样的马车，他们曾坐着它去瓦雷讷。所以路易上了
the coach. There are two members of the security services, I suppose you could say, sitting on either side. The abbé sits at the front and the whole way there, Louis is murmuring the prayer of the dying over and over to himself. Otherwise, he doesn't say anything. And as they set off, there are a hundred mounted police behind it, a hundred mounted members of the National Guard. So the rumbling of the wheels, the clopping of the horses, generally silence from the watching crowds who were masked behind the lines of the guards along the route. They set off at eight o'clock and it takes them two hours to get there. And in the course of those two hours, there are two royalist attempts to reach Louis.
马车。有两个安全部门的人员——我想你可以这么说——坐在两侧。神父坐在前面，一路上，路易都在反复喃喃自语着临终的祈祷。除此之外，他什么也没说。当他们出发时，后面跟着一百名骑警，一百名国民自卫队的骑兵。车轮的隆隆声、马蹄声，沿途被卫兵防线隔离在后的围观群众则总体保持沉默。他们于八点钟出发，花了两个小时才到达目的地。在这两个小时里，有两次保王派试图接近路易的行动。
They're both easily subdued, easily stopped, and at 10 o'clock the carriage arrives in the Place de la Révolution and it stands still for five minutes, and then Sanson's assistant steps up to it, opens up the door, the steps are pulled down, and Louis is seized by Sansan and his assistants. When they touch him, Louis loses his sense of composure because we've talked about that sense that the king's body is in violet, how dare people manhandle him. But then he catches the eye of his confessor of the Abbey and the Abbey kind of says, you know, don't do this. You don't need to do this. And clearly they've talked about the passion of Christ and essentially Louis is thinking, well, his savior suffered worse. So he accepts to be handled by the
它们都被轻易制服、轻易阻止了。10点钟，马车抵达革命广场，停了五分钟，随后桑松的助手走上前，打开车门，脚踏板放下，路易被桑松和他的助手们抓住。当他们触碰他时，路易失去了镇定，因为我们讨论过那种国王的身体神圣不可侵犯的观念，这些人怎么敢对拉拉扯扯。但接着他迎上了神父的目光，神父似乎在说：“你知道的，别这样。你不需要这样做。”显然他们谈论过基督受难，本质上路易心想，嗯，他的救世主遭受了更糟的痛苦。所以他接受了
executioners. So he then he takes off his coat and he pulls down his shirt so that his neck is open. His wrists are bound behind his back. His wig is taken off and then Sansol comes with the shears, with the clippers and his hair is cut so that the nape of his neck is exposed. He climbs up to the guillotine, he has to lean on the abbé because he's got his hands behind his back, so a bit unstable. And when he gets onto the scaffold, he tries to address the crowd and he seems to have uttered a few sentences. So according to various accounts, he says, people I die innocent of the crimes that they ascribe to me. I forgive the authors of my death and I pray to God that the blood you are about to spill will never fall back upon France." And at this point, there is a great drum roll. The captain
刽子手的触碰。接着他脱下外衣，拉下衬衫露出脖子。他的手腕在背后被绑住。假发被摘下，然后桑松拿着剪刀、修剪器剪短了他的头发，暴露出他的后颈。他爬上断头台，由于双手被反绑，他不得不倚靠着神父，显得有些摇晃。当他踏上绞刑台时，他试图向人群讲话，似乎说出了几句句子。根据各种说法，他说：“民众们，我为加在我身上的罪行感到无辜。我原谅我死刑的制造者，我祈祷上帝，你们即将流下的鲜血永远不会降临到法国头上。”就在这时，一阵巨大的鼓声响起。卫队队长
of the guard has been prepared to do this should Louis try to make a public speech. And so Louis' voice is drowned out. As the drums are rolling, Sansan's assistants get hold of Louis. They strap him down onto the board and they push him out so that his head is protruding ready for the blade to cut through the neck. It's Saint-Saens himself who pulls on the cord, the blade hisses down, cuts straight through Louis' neck and the head drops into the basket and it is 10.22am. Saint-Saens then does what he'd do with any beheaded criminal, he picks up the head and he shows it to the crowd and the people roar back in answer, Vive la Nation, Vive la République. There is then the sound of gunfire, of artillery to mark the moment and in the distant temple,
已经做好了准备，以防路易试图发表公开演讲。于是路易的声音被淹没了。在鼓点声中，桑松的助手们抓住了路易。他们把他绑在木板上，把他推出去，使他的脖子露出来，准备让刀片砍断脖子。正是桑松本人拉动了绳索，刀刃嘶嘶落下，径直切断了路易的脖子，人头落入篮中，时间是上午10点22分。桑松随后做了他对任何斩首罪犯都会做的事：他拿起人头向人群展示，人们齐声高呼回应：“法兰西万岁，共和国万岁。”随后传来了枪声和火炮声，标志着这一时刻的到来；在远处的圣殿里，
Marie Antoinette hears it, she knows what it signals and she drops to her knees before her son, who a few minutes before had been the Dauphin and now in the opinion of Marie-Antoinette and all royalists in France is Louis XVII. Crikey, what a moment. So you mentioned the crowd. The crowd of course are mainly troops because the ordinary people of Paris have been kept away from this moment. But within a couple of hours of this, am I not right in thinking that the troops have
玛丽·安托瓦内特听到了，她知道这意味着什么，她双膝跪倒在儿子面前，几分钟前他还是王太子，而现在在玛丽·安托瓦内特和法国所有保王派看来，他已经是路易十七了。天哪，真是个戏剧性的时刻！所以你提到了人群。人群当然主要是军队，因为巴黎的普通民众被挡在了这一时刻之外。但在这一切发生后的几个小时内，我是不是没记错的话，军队已经
moved away, people come into the streets, it's a little bit like on a public holiday, people are strolling around and, you know, it's January so it's not exactly that they're enjoying the sunshine, but people are acting as though it's just an ordinary Sunday or something, sort of taking the air as though nothing has happened. So Mara, a couple of days later, he describes the public mood on that day in the hours that follow Louis' execution. And he says that the people seemed animated with a serene joy. One might have said that they had just attended a religious festival. And he might well have put it like that because essentially, you know, and Mara is very conscious of this, what has been staged is a kind of ritual of sacrifice.
撤走了，人们走上街头，这有点像公众假期，人们在四处溜达，你知道，这是在一月，所以倒也不是说他们在享受阳光，但人们表现得好像这是一个普通的星期天什么的，像往常一样出来散步，仿佛什么都没发生过一样。因此马拉在几天后描述了路易被处决后几小时内的公众情绪。他说，人们似乎洋溢着一种宁静的喜悦。人们可能会说他们刚刚参加完一个宗教节日。他完全可以这样形容，因为本质上，你知道的，马拉对此有着清醒的认识，上演的是一种祭祀仪式。
And it's a sacrifice that has enabled the Republic to be born in a way that it had not previously been born. So Mara in the article he wrote on the 23rd, so two days after the execution, he goes on to say, the head of the tyrant has just fallen. The same blow has overthrown the foundations of monarchy among us. His life is no more. His body is now nothing but a corpse. At last, I believe in the Republic. So amazing, the Mara of all people, this is what it has taken for him to believe that the Republic exists at last. And there's a massive paradox here, because Louis did have to die as a king for the Republic to be born, because otherwise the sacrifice wouldn't have had the quality that it does have. But the moment he's dead
正是这种祭祀，使共和国以一种此前从未有过的方式得以诞生。因此，马拉在23日（即处决后两天）写的一篇文章中接着说：“暴君的头颅刚刚落地。同样的打击推翻了我们中间君主制的基石。他的生命不复存在。他的身体现在不过是一具尸体。最后，我终于相信了共和国。”太惊人了，竟然是马拉，这正是让他最终相信共和国确实存在的代价。这里有一个巨大的悖论，因为路易必须作为国王死去，共和国才能诞生，否则这种祭祀就不会具备它所拥有的特质。但就在他死去的那个瞬间，
and the Republic has been given existence, then his body has to be treated as though he had been nothing, as though he's just an ordinary citizen convicted of a crime. Nothing more, nothing less, no kind of special treatment in any way. So certainly, Louis' body is not allowed to be buried in the royal catacombs or anything like that. There had been a request before the execution from royalists for him to be buried next to his father, that had been denied. But at the same time, no special kind of desecration, no humiliations perpetrated on the corpse. Instead, he has to be buried, the convention has decreed, in the ordinary place of burial for citizens in a section that includes where he will be executed. That's what they've said. So, just as though he's any other condemned criminal. So, he gets taken to the church that serves as
共和国宣告诞生，他的遗体就必须被当作什么都不是来对待，就像是一个因犯罪而被定罪的普通公民一样。不多不少，没有任何形式的特权。因此，路易的遗体肯定不被允许埋葬在皇家墓穴或类似的地方。处决前保王派曾请求将他埋葬在他父亲旁边，这遭到拒绝。但与此同时，也没有对尸体进行任何特殊的亵渎或羞辱。相反，国民公会已下令，他必须被埋葬在公民的普通墓地里，埋葬在一个包括他被处决地点在内的区域。他们就是这么说的。所以，就像任何其他被判刑的罪犯一样。于是他被带到那座充当
the burial ground for executed criminals. His funeral service is conducted not by the abbé, who had been his confessor, but by a priest who is acceptable to the Republic, to the revolutionaries. His body is then thrown into a ditch on a bed of quicklime, which will help it become kind of mulch. The head is tossed in as well, and then it's covered by more quicklime. So this is a communal grave. There is to be no marker.
被处决罪犯墓地的教堂。他的葬礼不是由曾担任其神父的修道院院长主持的，而是由一位共和国和革命者能够接受的神父主持的。然后他的遗体被扔进了一条铺有生石灰的沟里，生石灰会帮助它分解成某种腐殖质。头颅也被扔了进去，然后盖上更多的生石灰。所以这是一个乱葬岗。不会有任何标记。
Instead, it is left mingled up with other corpses where it will decompose. The whole thing, it's no special treatment whatsoever. Yeah. And that's the intention. But of course, in the long run, it turns out neither side really content with this spin on the execution of Louis or the fate of his body. And so for royalists, obviously, this is a terrible crime. And as it happened with Charles the first, so with Louis the 16th, it doesn't
相反，它与其他尸体混杂在一起任其分解。整个过程没有任何特殊对待。是的。这就是本意。但当然，从长远来看，双方实际上都对路易处决或其遗体命运的这种舆论包装感到不满。因此，对于保王派来说，这显然是一桩可怕的罪行。正如查理一世的遭遇一样，对于路易十六，他们也没有
take them long before they are comparing Louis' fate to that of Christ. Right. A martyr. He's a martyr. Yeah, he's a Christian martyr. A martyr for the monarchy, but above all a martyr for the true church. But Republicans as well, and it may be that they are reacting to the kind of the royalist propaganda, they find it impossible to rest content with the idea that Louis had died simply as a common criminal. So already within a week of Louis's execution, you get newspapers claiming that his death, rather than being what it had been, which was something wholly unexceptional, that had been the whole point, had actually been something shameful and disgraceful.
花多长时间就将路易的命运与基督的命运进行比较。对，一个殉道者。他是一个殉道者。是的，他是一个基督教殉道者。君主制的殉道者，但最重要的是真正教会的殉道者。但共和国也是如此，他们可能是对保王派宣传的一种反应，发现自己无法安于“路易仅仅作为一个普通罪犯死去”这种想法。因此，在路易被处决后的一周内，报纸上就已经开始出现各种说法，声称他的死并非原本那种毫无特殊性、本该平淡无奇的结局，而实际上是一件极其可耻和耻辱的事。
So in one paper, you get an account account, the instant that speech was so brutally taken from him by a definite beating of drums, Louis entered into a violent anger, stamped his foot, struggled with vigor with the executioner's assistance, let out terrible cries and fought to the end to such an extent that he had not his neck, but the back of his head and his jaw horribly mutilated by the fatal knife. So this is a claim that is quite often made that it took two goes of the guillotine to sever his neck. Which is not true. And also there are reports that as he died, he let out a piercing scream.
所以在某家报纸上，你看到这样一段记述：就在那一瞬间，当路易的演讲被一阵明确的鼓点残忍地打断时，路易勃然大怒，跺着脚，在刽子手助手的协助下进行剧烈的挣扎，发出可怕的尖叫声，并一路抗争到底，以至于致命的刀刃割伤的不是他的脖子，而是他的后脑勺和下巴，被恐怖地残害了。这是一个经常被提出的说法，即断头台切断他的脖子花了两下。这并不是真的。此外还有报道称，当他死去时，他发出了刺耳的尖叫。
Again, not true. You know, his vocal cords have been severed. And there are also claims which supposedly derived from Sansan and Sansan, you know, they become so repeated that Sansan actually has to publicly reject them that on the night before his execution and the hours before he's taken to the guillotine, Louis had been stuffing his face. And this is to repeat the old child, you know, that he's the pig, the pig king. And there are accounts that, you know, he'd been so fat that he hadn't fitted onto the board that, you know, that he's executed on. And there's another one
同样，这不是真的。你知道的，他的声带已经被割断了。还有一些据称源自桑松的说法——桑松，你知道的，这些谣言被重复了太多次，以至于桑松不得不公开予以否认——即在被处决的前天晚上以及被带到断头台前的几个小时里，路易一直在大吃大喝。这是在重复那个老掉牙的谣言，你知道的，他是那个猪头国王。还有说法称，你知道的，他太胖了，以至于装不上用来处决他的那块木板；还有另一种说法
that he's, you know, he's the bulges and folds of his neck had been so obese that it wouldn't fit in the slot. Again, not true. I mean, simply not true. Yeah. Because of course he'd been fasting because for religious reasons. Yes, he had. And so it's an attempt to kind of contradict that. And what it does, of course, is to ensure that Louis' execution, rather than providing, as it were, a clear cut between the Age of Monarchy and the Republic, and that the Republic is now uncontested, it's not uncontested at all. The way in which both royalists and Republicans try and rewrite the story of Louis' execution actually bodes very ill for France because it suggests that there are deep, entrenched, principled opinions about what has been done, that there isn't really
是，你知道的，他脖子上的赘肉和褶皱太肥了，根本塞不进那个槽里。同样，这不是真的。我的意思是，根本不是真的。是的，因为他出于宗教原因一直在斋戒。是的，他确实在斋戒。所以这是一种试图反驳这种说法的尝试。而这样做的结果，当然是确保了路易的处决不仅没有在君主制时代和共和国之间划清界限、让共和国从此无可争议——事实上它远非无可争议。保王派和共和党人试图改写路易处决故事的方式，实际上对法国来说是个极不祥的预兆，因为这表明，对于所发生的事情，存在着深厚、根深蒂固且原则性的分歧，人们实际上
any hope of reconciling them. And it suggests that even though perhaps the foreign threats to France have been beaten off, although who knows for how long now that the King has been executed, who knows what the international response to that will be. But that may not be the worst of it, because it suggests that actually within the body of France itself a civil war may be brewing. Wow what a dramatic end to the third series on the French Revolution. Season three has come to an end with the execution of Louis XVI but many of the big players are still around and in play. Mary Antoinette, Rob Spear, Tonton Mara in season four, which will be coming later this year, we will find out what happens to all of those characters.
没有任何和解的希望。这表明，即便法国面临的外部威胁可能已经被击退——尽管在国王被处决后，谁知道国际社会的反应会如何，这种和平能维持多久呢——但这可能还不是最糟糕的，因为它表明法国国内本身实际上可能正在酝酿一场内战。哇，法国大革命第三季迎来了多么戏剧性的结局！第三季以路易十六的处决落下帷幕，但许多重量级人物仍然活跃在舞台上。玛丽·安托瓦内特、罗伯斯庇尔、丹东、马拉……在将于今年晚些时候播出的第四季中，我们将知晓所有这些角色的结局。
A little spoiler alert for you. None of them make it into, well, they definitely won't be around in season six or seven, will they? That's, that's for sure. So there's an awful lot of drama, a lot of bloodshed to come. No doubt in our forthcoming bonus episodes for the Mercedez history club members, we'll be talking about some of the issues that have come up in this series, but thank you for listening.
给你们一个小剧透。他们中没有一个人能活到——嗯，他们绝对活不到第六季或第七季，对吧？那是肯定的。所以未来还有大量的戏剧性和血腥事件。毫无疑问，在我们即将推出的“历史其余部分”俱乐部会员专属加更节目中，我们将讨论本系列中出现的一些议题，但感谢大家的收听。
We will return to the French revolution later in the year. Tom, merci beaucoup et au revoir. Au revoir. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们将在今年晚些时候回归法国大革命。Tom，merci beaucoup et au revoir（汤姆，非常感谢，再见）。Au revoir（再见）。本集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。